[Music]
it's one of the most iconic hairstyles
of all time
bangs also known as fringe but we'll get
to that later
bangs have been immortalized by
countless movie stars and cultural icons
so where did bangs come from how does
one cut them and what does having bangs
say about the women bold enough to wear
them this is how bangs took over the
world
bangs date all the way back to the
eighth century people often credit the
Egyptian queen Cleopatra for bringing
them into style but that's just a myth
historians say the credit should go to
this guy his name was Surya
an Iraqi Renaissance man known to have
started the trend which as this painting
shows was also adopted by his female
fans over the next thousand years
bangs became an institution evident in
countless paintings of European women in
the 18th and 19th centuries with the
dawn of motion pictures silent film
stars like Louise Brooks made bangs and
iconic style of the roaring 20s
then came the era of the pin-up girl
pioneered by the notorious Bettie Page
Europe moved back into the spotlight in
the swinging 60s with iconic looks by
model Peggy Moffitt and singer Jane
Birkin only in Europe they don't call
them bangs they call it fringe which is
what the style is known as pretty much
everywhere except the u.s. so French
continued to evolve and sometimes the
results were mixed
but the look has endured and some of the
most iconic women in the world have made
sure that bangs or fringe whatever you
want to call it is one of the most
sought after styles on the planet and
those brave enough to get them usually
come with inspiration I love Taylor so
stings Taylor Swift Taylor Swift I'm a
stone reese witherspoon Alexa Chung
natalia dyer Zooey Deschanel Zooey
Deschanel have some great bangs so how
does one actually get bangs well that
depends on the type of bangs are going
for theirs blunt wispy shaggy choppy
curly side-swept the options are endless
[Music]
we went to Prima hair in the Lower East
Side of Manhattan to see how it's done
for both straight and curly hair when
summer with straight hair comes in for a
fringe generally we'll want to blow dry
the whole all of the hair forward to
make sure that we don't have any
partings in there draw the hair to the
center go ahead and cut and then soften
that line in through there
when someone has curly hair because the
hair doesn't quite sit the same way I
like to go through and cut each curl
individually to make sure that it's a
following the line in through there but
also shows movement as the curls go but
you don't have to go to a salon to get
fabulous bangs lots of women prefer to
do it themselves
[Music]
carefully so why do women get bangs well
let's ask them
my beings are a hundred percent a part
of my identity I just kind of wanted
this whole new look for a new chapter
sometimes I just like to switch it up
kind of cliche but I actually went to
Paris and a lot of girls had them and
they just looked so good I like the way
that they frame my face I feel like I
like myself with them more I grow them
at once and I absolutely hated it and
never did it again it was the first time
my haircut really felt like me because
it wasn't like my mom picking my
hairstyle for the first couple of days
it might want to live like this after a
week or so that fringe will start to
settle into its new position and make
your life a whole lot easier
bangs may look effortless but
maintaining them is anything but things
are super high maintenance it's easy to
put them in your hair but once they're
there it's a commitment for sure I
straighten them everyday with a
straightener the day's just split up
between pulling out the comb and
brushing them back down when it's really
windy out and like the winds hitting you
in both directions and then it goes up
and then you're like no that's not how I
look I promise in fact they can be so
high-maintenance it makes some women
swear off fringe forever
I actually am trying to grow out my
veins right now the one reason why I
hated them was because it was just like
an extra step in the morning I had bangs
of the baby because in the 90s that's
just normal
can you see this look how cute I was I
don't know people usually ask me oh why
I love
you had bangs and I'm like you loved me
with bangs but you wouldn't love having
them yourself that's pretty much what it
is it's just too much work but there are
shortcuts like these clip-in bangs which
don't require the months it takes to
grow them back out
bangs have been around for centuries
representing some of the most iconic
style moments of all time they may be a
lot of work but one thing is pretty
certain they're never going out of style
[Music]
I don't know just my face was way too
round for them and then after a while
I'd wear them on the side like that like
you can't really see that but like they
wouldn't fully cover my head like and
another thing is when you're growing
them out like some of these pictures I
have this is a picture of me doing it
whoops